each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
found this project we've been sort of
working for a couple of years it
originated in this ill-fated thought a
lifelong program that was the call sore
proposals about that where they're
looking to some instrument people and
recover their activities and when I was
liquid that I was thinking you know I
bet you could do a lot of this just by
getting the audio and so the sort of the
motivation is to sort of try that out
and see how much information how and
what kind of useful information you can
get out of a personal archive if you
only have audio recordings so let's talk
a little bit about what we mean by that
and then some of the work we've been
doing just to investigate what we can
make or how to make this work segmenting
and clustering the audio you're looking
at detecting the speech segments and
looking for repeated events and I'll
talk available at the end about our
efforts to develop some tools to make
this easier to do so the to me the kind
of the the fascinating motive is that
it's it's technically very simple
straightforward to make continuous
recording so this here is an mp3 player
it's a hundred dollars and it has a
microphone built-in you know they sort
of thought well we're going to build
this device we might as well make it
possible to have people record lectures
or whatever but because it's got a
gigabyte of memory and it can record
easily for we can record 30 hours worth
of audio and it turns out but with a
single double a battery it can record
for 12 hours continuously so I can just
put this on my belt turn it on and walk
around and record everything no problem
and when I upload it it's still only a
couple of gigabytes a week so it's
actually very manageable it's something
you can carry around this audio and it's
that the storage problem is solved but
once you've got these recordings they're
almost entirely opaque the idea of
having the 48 hour recording and trying
to find something in it what are you
going to do you know you can sort of try
and do binary search to try and plan a
particular point but it's really painful
really difficult because the sort of
figure out where you are you have to
listen to some several seconds of audio
and this is it is a very very awkward
process so the sort of the the sad fact
is even though I've made a lot of these
recordings I I don't have any good
stories about times when they're useful
right I still haven't really found
anything that really is compelling about
using them although that's kind of the
thing we're still looking for and it
seems like there's got to be something
useful that you can do there's got to be
an answer to this so the project is to
see what kinds of tools we can develop
to help with to make these things useful
and to help accessing them this idea of
minimal impact has a couple of
dimensions one is but because we're
because you're making a recording like
this with a an audio based device that
doesn't have to have line of sight and
it's just sort of has to be body worn
the actual process of recording has very
low impact on on the person making
recordings the other aspect is that the
if you want to bet say there's a small
you know a small fraction of the states
which may be useful and you have to make
it so that the economics of record the
information is sufficient to sort of
payback for that relic relatively modest
utility so you want to make it very
simple for people to record the data and
store it and manage it because if it's
any amount of effort and they're not
getting lot of payback they won't do it
at all so that's another sort of thing
we're thinking about how can we just
make it easy to build these kinds of of
archives so what kind of information can
we hope to get from these recordings
well if we have these long-duration
recordings we can reasonably expect to
be able to figure out the location where
someone is that basically you know if
you've got like if you're in a
particular place for ten minutes you've
got the recordings of the ambient
background noise that's fairly
characteristic of a particular location
and activity so both the place and the
kind of thing are doing whether you're
you know walking around having
conversation etc obviously once we get
into the more detailed sound information
we can expect to get information about
people so we can met Beth can be a
various levels of detail from just
generic information while there were
several there were two different males
speaking or ideally more specific
information where we identified
individual people speaking this this
begins to sound like interesting things
allow and then of course as we go to
another level of veto we could actually
maybe get the words out which when you
think about it that's often kind of its
it's both feet it's the crux of a lot of
this imp love this stuff people have
very ambivalent feelings about having
that information preserved but it is
clearly information that people care
about things we can't get of course only
using the audio the visual things what
what people and things look like the
things that you can get with with a
sense camp and obviously some sort of
corresponding attributes things like the
difference in day and night is
relatively easy to get out of images
very hard to go from the audio except
indirectly and things about how people
are things that people do but don't
result in sounds so when they look in
sick the directions and absolutely can't
get information so they can't get
everything but we can get a lot and
particularly for the kinds of goals of
the of the order of the lifelog program
which was like trying to describe the
sequence activities someone did this
seems quite quite feasible so the kinds
of applications we're looking at our
this kind of automatic appointment book
history this thing which says okay oh
during this recording this is what you
did you had a meeting you you know you
went somewhere else you have lunch
whatever when you have a collection of
data which is very extended you can
imagine sort of gathering statistics on
your life which are you know aggregated
over a longer period so how much time I
spend in meetings you know who what's my
pattern of people I speak to even things
like one of my particular idioms that I
use a lot of things that I don't know if
that's important but it would be kind of
cute to be able to get that out
obviously there's this obvious thing of
wanting of if you can recall exactly
what you or someone else said that's
sort of what we spend a lot of time
doing so this is one possibility to try
and shift the balance there one thing
that sort of came up on so make these
recordings is that there is a funny kind
of nostalgia aspect to reviewing these
recordings which is kind of akin to
looking at snapshots and it's
interesting talking you know what we've
heard this morning about the the in the
particular link between images and
memory
there is also some kind of my info
oscillation is there some kind of
emotive link between hearing hearing a
particular piece of speech and you're
you're you're sort of you know affective
memory of that and that's sort of
something that's been very under
underutilized but really you know we're
trying we want to understand better what
applications could be used for this data
and the one the way we can try and find
this out is actually collecting the data
until we have a record like this
available is sort of there's no real
reason to think about things you could
do with it because well you don't have
the data so a lot of it was a lot of
this project was kind of leap of faith
to say well let's just start collecting
this data and hopefully we'll figure out
something useful to do with it later on
one sometimes I think about the people
who want to get their heads frozen
cryogenically when they fall sick
because you know in the 50 years time
we'll be able to do all this stuff with
with with that and I kind of feel like
we're a little bit in that kind of
ballgame that with thinking what we
don't know what to do yet but maybe if
we make the recordings now does the only
chance we're going to get to make those
okay so let me just quickly tell you
about a few of the things that we've
been doing with this data the first
thing we want to do was just say okay
we've got these very long recordings
what is the sort of them for the
coarsest kind of information when I try
to go out of this which is structuring
this thing is a series of slightly
shorter episodes which are consistent
and this is you know something that we
there are a bunch of tools available if
you sort of know how to start doing this
so the idea is you know for try and
think about the diary application can be
segments for recording up into these
different things that happened i was in
lecture i was in a meeting i was walking
walking home or whatever compared to a
typical audio analysis problem like
speech recognition this composes some
rather different requirements so
typically we have a frame rate in in
speech recognition of like 100 frames a
second but here we reached in a much
longer time scales are actually our
basic time frames need to be much longer
and we were looking like one minute long
time frame so we just looking the Cystic
so every every minute of the recording
if we're interested in these kind of
slowly changing attributes then so the
background is actually more important in
the foreground so that's why we want to
have something that average is out that
behavior over a minute so that the sort
of the variation foreground kind of gets
washed out but the consistent things in
the background are the most prominent
parts of that information and then it
seems sensible to use perceptually
motivated features because obviously
we're trying to we're trying to get at
things that people would notice as well
you could argue about both ways because
it may be if there's information that
people don't notice for which houses a
task that could be helpful to but there
was some background and perceptual stuff
that we've done so the kinds of features
we're using so these are spectrograms
that is the conventional time frequency
representation but here the time is like
eight hours or so or six six or eight
hours of recording and on different
different frequency axis these are
actually frequency embarq which is an
auditory you know an ear ear model scale
this is the energy on average in two
different domains and then these are the
sort of the variations of energy within
each one minute frame which is also a
useful kind of second aspect and then we
had this thing which we call spectral
entropy which is a based a lot of other
measures basically how complex the
spectrum is within each individual
frequency band so whether it's broadly
spread out or focused in a few bands and
this again gives us the latest English
things which might look very similar in
these average energy representations
what we see here is you begin to see
like there are these pic champs but I
think the same and then there are
changes and sort of see the the logic of
trying to segment the audio up into
these different longer longer segments
so use the technique called the basic
information criteria pick which is a
thing's been used as pitch recognition
for segmenting different speaker turns
we have a database of like eight days of
recordings which that's 62 hours we were
you meaning my student hand hand mark
this into sort of 139 different segments
for about 20 minutes eh on average and
he assigned those two 16 different
category so it was his data that was he
was nothing
and then we basically want to see how
well we could actually yeah there's
something the mystic curious because
audio is linear how long did it take him
to do this isn't a long time frame
tomorrow that was that mean see we have
a lot more data toughness but this was
like the most i could possibly ask him
to mark up in 139 segments is not a lot
and but it was like it was very very
difficult it will be hard even my head
yeah I haven't comfortable fun we doing
this is kind before we had any tools
available so it was a he's a very he's a
very dedicated student so we're able to
look at different features were using
and measure ability to recall to find
these particular boundaries that we've
hand mark and actually this works pretty
well I mean as you'd expect from this
pictures there's some some extent you
know because he knew what system we were
going to use when these markings
boundaries has some this is an
optimistic measure but it seems like we
can actually get many boundaries pretty
accurately and you incidentally these
are auditory model features work a lot
better than standard nfcc features which
are sort of down here and in recall okay
so now we were able to break this
recording up into these sort of roughly
half hour long segments when things are
happening so now we want to sort of see
if we can figure out that different
segments that we say whether we broken
up correspond to the same events we have
these 16 categories of events and this
is the kind of similarity matrix we've
sorted the difference 139 segments by
the different labels and then was shown
on the picture here a black dot means
that they're very similar by this
measure we're using which is the the KL
distance which is measure similarity
between probability distributions and we
see that yeah roughly speaking many of
these categories are similar themselves
and distal of the others although there
seems like for this one for the
restaurant class they're like three
different sub categories which are all
kind of mutually dissimilar and some
other think there's clear outliers hear
that some of these library events are
different from the others but basically
that looks very hopeful so then were
able to use a clustering technique
called spectral clustering which brings
these things together find several this
no finds a way of as assignments as
similar categories and were able to
evaluate that the actual cat the
category / Custer's we come out we get
out our anonymous but we can sort of do
the best job of making correspond to the
ground trees clusters and we can measure
this correct correct rate and we get
like seventy percent correct which is
not great but it's sort of it's useful
and so this is a typical result here's a
whatever a ten-hour recording here are
the actual segments we could
automatically here are the labels we
assigned automatically where I've sort
of given them the actual names that do
the best job and here's the ground truth
and you know it's not it's not perfect
it's not even though good but it's you
know it's getting some useful
information out there okay so that was
kind of our first experiment and it was
sort of our first exposure to what was
what the data was like what it was
useful for and one of the things we
noticed was that the speech content
which would sort of been shying away
from because of the privacy problems
with it really was very important and
was very interesting something that we'd
want to be able to index and access
estates are through so then we stood
looking the problem saying well maybe
forget us detect where the speeches and
these recordings that will be a useful
kind of indexing attribute and sometimes
it's may be useful to the Texas features
present even though the speech itself is
no intelligible so here's an example of
recording where the speech loan toes
will be clearly speech is present first
a recording from a coffee shop actually
nearby here and a few people speaking
and you can sort of tell their people
speaking and might even be able to tell
identify one or two other speakers but
you can't really understand what they're
saying that's a typical kind of thing
we've got here so the what what do
people use failed to recognize speech
well our hypothesis is that a lot of
that you pick up on the pitch track of
the speech was a particular shape of
fitrec which is very characteristic of
speech and maidenly character Steve
individual speakers so what we've been
working on is developing a way of
extracting the pitch track in this kind
of high noise data using that as a basis
for her voice detection so here's
another recording my student canceled a
tilting summers friends
how cute and what is not my people this
is this is typical of the kind of data
that we're working with its does a lot
of background noise it was outside
there's some air conditioner went in the
background and what happens when we run
a conventional pitch tracker is that
there's a strong sort of continuous
pitch that it picks up which is the kind
of the foot rumble of the air
conditioning noise and if we don't take
that we sort of we make a lot of
mistakes so we developed this system of
compensating for steady-state
periodicity to help remove those and
then we get the sort of concert pitch
wrecked it just picks up on the variable
pitch track and that seems to be the
important part for helping people
recognize that the voices present is
this this the non stationarity of the
pictures so here on a 15 minute test
savage again we had to manually mark as
voice present or not we're getting like
almost ninety percent accuracy for
marking a speech present or absent
versus something less than eighty
percent when we don't have this
conversation please who leaves their
study background sounds we can also use
these pitch Trax it for the accurate
pitch Trax we can use them to enhance
the speech just by filtering speech that
has a particular parisa t we've actually
looking at that both for this kind of
stuff and for speech recognition as well
okay another thing yeah yeah
that's a nice idea so we've with we
thought about this problem of how you
make it unintelligible if you if you've
got a problem if you want to disc
rambling and we've spoken about you know
the necessity to have an accurate voice
to take to do this but we haven't
thought about using that for that that
process I think the thing is like if you
want to make if you if you don't want
specially recognizable it's very easy to
guarantee that you just don't store
enough for the waveform to be able to
reconstruct it so you just store the
spectrogram or whatever and then you
can't get back that information but it
if you want to have a selective thing
where sometimes you sometimes you
scramble it because you don't have a
confidence that you can that you can
record it and sometimes you don't then
that that's the kind of that's the basis
that you need but that you also need to
speak identification on top of that and
that's what we're looking at now the
speaker identification and these high
noise conditions is proving pretty hard
and a lot of progress on that okay so
another thing he wants to do was to
identify where there are it is the idea
of like here's my big archival audio can
you find events that happen a lot of
times here and we don't know what
they're going to be but just to live
search through them and that becomes a
very a problem of tractability that you
know if I wants to compare every one
second frame against every other one
second frame in this you know 62 our
data set that would be a lot of
comparisons so to try and make that to
try and speed that up we're using this
hashing approach which is similar some
work that's been done done here by
Michael McCauley where we describe the
audio by these sort of small discreet
hashes and then rather than having to
search linearly to really press the
database we can just have a table which
says well these hashes are curly seven
points and you can quickly check each of
those and it's much much quicker the
particular fingerprint on hashing
technique using is a thing from Shazam
company that does music matching over
cell phones and it's based on these sort
of prominent time-frequency edges but if
there's it sort of goes through and it
filters out a few of these sort of
places where energy suddenly starts and
then stores the sort of
distance and time and frequency between
pairs of these and that's the basic hash
element and the nice thing about this is
that doesn't really depend on the
background noise just depends on the
strongest pieces of foreground energy
and but it's still relatively simple and
so that works really well for music
detection for them this is an example of
a cell phone ringing or something okay
whatever signal else do it anyway but
you can see the sort of this nice
pattern of in the audio there as well
and then what we can do is you know for
a piece of piece of audio we can go
through we can look for recurrences of
the hashes on the sort of n square
matrix of seeing where they come up so
this is like actually a 45 minute
recording where there were three
telephone rings and so here's one
telephone ring here's another and here's
another and you see these little matches
there's also some music and it's found
these recurrences a particular music
track that was listening to this is
based on this kind of recording there's
kind of a body worn like recording so
the actual repeats are very different
they go back different background noise
and different recording conditions but
the the the fingerprint is robust enough
to find that so works well when when his
exact structure in the audio repeats but
it doesn't work well for things like he
was trying to make it work with the
Sanders garage door which sort of seems
like you should be the same but it's not
only terminal enough and there's enough
mechanical variation that it didn't it
didn't repeat well so this is this is
kind of trade-off between how how
precise your your hash is you want to be
reasonably precise so you don't get a
lot of spurious hits but if it's too
precise then you start noticing the
difference between different events that
you would actually consider to be
similar okay so um that's sort of the
projects we've been doing a moment the
other stuff we've been looking at and
working in the future is is looking at
these ways of being able to facilitate
access this data so we yeah
how do we write so how do we how do we
get this so it's a question in the
previous slide your head you had a
spectrogram right here are you sure
these oh these access but how do you do
that looping to find fundamental unit
that you need to find repeating right so
there's no there's no grouping this is
this is done continuously of the whole
bow do and all this so what we're seeing
here is just you know the with each one
of these little blue circles is a is a
match between two time points and so
they're not that you know then this
particular telephone rings you know
maybe eight to ten different matches
that they've their temporary custard so
that's when I time period and then you
when you do this match against itself
you find this grouping right exactly the
little little cluster of things to come
out and then they face to the form is
nice local accident videos this one's
this one is interesting so so these
music is probably you know anybody
seconds are no longer there's quite
sparse it has a mattress on every every
you know 50 milliseconds or whatever but
still sorry we haven't done you can
imagine having something that recognizes
the bear you know they pick us up
together in bad as things a distinct as
a president okay
so again together this issue of what
what what is this useful for and can we
find these useful applications really is
important to have a way that's has low
impact allows you look at this data so
we've been looking at trying to build
front ends which I have to say is not
really our area of expertise but it sort
of is you know it's it's inescapable
that's kind of stuff so we have this
kind of diary interface where we have
the audio is a sort of pseudo
spectrogram where we're using color
chroma and intensity to to carry
different factors and then we have some
extra information here which is actually
grabbed from my online diary then these
are them the automatically generated
segments and labels that go along with
this and again you know this alone the
ordinates automatic labels alone on very
good for finding things but in
conjunction with what what you hadn't
made notes that you're going to do that
day anyway then you can sort of
correlate these much better I'll show
you this in a second that this thing
actually running we've been looking at
putting other information is this such
as like whip looking at the email outbox
and seeing when you send emails sort of
again remind you exactly what you're
doing to take the time and one thing we
want to do is to synchronize this with
with pictures with images such as things
that we've might go to get from the
sense cancer you could actually again
see what was see what image was and help
use that to help you find a particular
time point to listen to and then you
click on the audio click on spectrogram
you can hear the audio okay we've also
been looking at ways of doing thumbnails
like happy summarizes 10-hour recording
into something you could listen to less
than 10 hours and there's sort of some
fun things you can do like taking in
half a second every minute and sort of
cross fading them and it actually gives
you a an interesting feeling for what's
going on although it's it's kind of just
quite impressionistic it's not really
robust what we what what are one of our
goals this year is to release some tools
for other people be able to do this so
because ideally you know you can anyone
can make these recordings anyone can buy
this thing it's nothing that special
hardware here they can upload them onto
that machine they can make their own
recordings if we can give them the
software ticking just drop this in
disappear then that sort of doesn't seem
like that look at that hard to do and if
we could get in you know if we could
facilitate other people using this then
maybe we can find out more interesting
uses for this kind of technology another
thing we're both thinking about is
applying speech recognition first I've
been involved in this project on meeting
recordings which has most mercy speech
recognition wooden workers can
effectively the speech recognition is
not good at these high background noises
but there is his several celebrities
working on these recordings of meetings
and civic this is an example of the
meeting recorded meeting data that we
collected and a bunch of mike friends
here on the table which are generate
which are recording similar kinds of
information that you get from a body
worn or audio recorder and so there is
progress being made on this kind of task
of looking to try and apply some of this
on these recordings obviously if you
were serious about trying to record
speech and transcribe it you'd probably
work a little harder at getting a high
quality signal in the first place and
probably wouldn't use a single
microphone so we could wear think about
trying to use maybe just 22 of these
things just to get at least two samples
you could do some kind of blind
beamforming on or even generating a
special you know special purpose
directional microphone that would
actually try and pick figure out whether
speech was and record that expert and
higher quality so finally privacy and
security something that's been a very
you know always that the always present
in this project I hope and we're going
to get to talk about this in general a
little more because you know there was a
little bit discussion on email people
very often react very negatively when
you say is it okay if I record our
conversation and of course it's actually
illegal in certain places i'm not sure
if it's legal in Washington on
Washington State there's this
interesting project that that right
medial i was doing ways recording
everything in his house no with his kid
growing up sees you can figure out how
the kid bootstraps language and they
have a few approaches that i have this
thing where they have an oops button but
they can delete you know the last
minutes worth of audio every time they
they get something they don't they think
they didn't want to record that was very
easy to talk to the original carp a
workshop in 2004 by the love check when
she was talking about the issues that
once you start
recording this data they're all these
kind of interesting legal things that
even if you don't want it to be used it
can be subpoenaed and so you know you
have to worry about exactly what you're
exposing yourself to if you collect this
data so the access to report is very
sensitive but so the preservation I mean
one of the things I do want to make
these recordings is I'm very I'm kind of
paranoid about making copies of them
because you know if you do lose it you
never get the chance to record it again
and that's kind of interesting tension
between ones have redundancy wouldn't
make sure no one else can connects us
the data so the moment but they have
recorded is all on DVDs and a disk but
they're offline they're not they're not
on the net and I my students per student
his native his recordings similarly his
data is not on a surface anywhere he
doesn't you know I had to give
permission to use the little chumbo
flayger earlier of course if we're if
we're really worried about speech we can
just make sure that the let's meet
restore is not intelligible and in fact
maybe we could actually run the speech
recognizer on the original data then
throw it away then you've got this kind
of semi reliable transcript because
we've organizers make those mistakes so
if you can say oh that's not what I said
at all the speech recognizer is not like
gonna say no it's definitely you said
because no one believes that so it's
kind of interesting middle ground maybe
if that works out different approaches
to try and you know preserve different
levels of access and security and
different you know ways of there are a
lot of a lot of privacy experts think
about these kinds of problems all right
so conclusion personal audio is
something that we can easily collect and
manage I mean very easily it's one
hundred dollars to buy a recorder or
less but the problem is making it useful
we've looked at these problems with the
task of segmentation which turns out to
be pretty successful we looked at voice
detection which is working pretty well
it's a question that's sort of a
question of how far down you know how
how noisy it has to be for you don't
care whether the voice is there or not
and we're looking at speaker
identification but that's still work in
progress dislike this problem of finding
these arbitrary repeating events i think
is kind of interesting again we've just
got this working on the scale of like an
hour long recording i think it'd be
really nice when you can actually make
this work on you know hundreds of hours
and see what kind of things come out we
haven't quite got there going yet and
then we're working on these distribution
of
tools so just in the last second or so
this is the the interface i showed you
here with the the automatically
generated labels in the diary
advancement so you can just click here
and and i was happening with it because
it does actually playback stuff so do we
know why we're not getting one you're
okay whatever the audio site but you can
even click in you get this stuff was
written this is that this is a very kind
of shaky thing that I wrote in in TCL
what council has done in 30 places in
Java which is something is just much
more cross platform or something we can
adapt and n distribute this is going to
be the basis of our other tools that we
hope to make available later this year
okay that's very any questions
yeah answer I took half an hour as well
it seems like you know we're not doing
very well I am ok any questions it's
really interesting alyssa was wondering
if you've been thinking about I mean so
pick up understanding the environmental
characteristics can play a very
interesting tool in other applications
so in one of the things about the
research budgets are working on these
sound characteristics are very fought
for us to know to figure out how do we
get in touch with this person so i'm i'm
working in in context aware routing of
messages so this company's very just
been how do we get in touch with this
person the vidiians know is this person
is in the mall in the library or maybe
this person is having dinner or so they
want to figure out how do we are out
this message so you need to have some
understanding what what is the sound
environment so that if it's quiet mega
in column yes it really loud maybe I
shouldn't so maybe having this
understanding of what's going on can
help in applications such as that front
the other issue is thinking about is
that a traditional problem in speech
recognition is that you do recognition
in a chain environments right but you do
it for one person I was wondering if you
have a history of recordings then it
turns out that there's repetitiveness in
location could it be that you could
change for those environments for this
person you got something that you think
that can happen it's a semester
yeah that is that's a that's a big issue
that in general in any kind of cystic or
modeling the more you know about more
you Betty that will closely and
characterize the interference the better
you can do and so if you suddenly have
this history available you know you can
suddenly get as much yeah yeah yeah
that's a great idea it's a recently